ce weekend se tenait l'épopée médiévale
de loche et dans les ruelles du marché
menant au donjon on pouvait croiser des
personnages étranges et vous monsieur
qu'est-ce que je faux pour vous petit
filtre d'amour petite potion de
gloire et vous madame monsieur il est
encore assez
efficace ça marche comme vous voulez
allons brave Gan il n'y a là que de bons
emboûtements pour vous débarrasser de
vos voisins devenus trop
gênant
théâtre de rue mais aussi atelier
présentation d'objets stand d'artisans
et grands spectacles la manifestation
minsi l'utile à
l'agréable sur notre site on ait une
ambiance textile avec une certaine envie
de parler de l'histoire et d'en parler
correctement c'est-à-dire de faire appel
à enfin de de lutter contre des idées
reçues à savoir que tous les gens
Moyen-Âge étaient moches bossu et puis
infirme et c'était des gens comme nous
et puis de faire parler en fait un peu
plus l'époque racontant plein plein de
choses et le moyen-âge passionne
jusqu'au plus jeune dégisé en quoi là en
chevalier en chevalier en chevalier de
quand du Moyen-Âge parce que ils font
des
combats parmi les visiteurs certains
sont venus costumer des afficinados des
fêtes médiévales qui ne rateraient pour
rien au monde celle de loche oh il y en
a beaucoup en France il y en a à peu
près entre 700 et 800 chaque année donc
on peut pas être partout donc mais là le
je reviens chaque année parce que
vraiment le spectacle est très bien à
l'origine la manifestation se déroulait
à la forteresse royale de Chinon mais
pendant les travaux c'est la commune de
loche qui se charge de l'organiser
depuis même si Chinon a relancé la
sienne elle s'est maintenue à loche et
attire chaque année quelques 10000
visiteurs